awesome
now that video was shot by our next
guest from the Mexican side of the
Border in Juarez it shows a huge mass of
migrants lined up of course they're
waiting for title 42 to expire and thus
they're just going to enter the United
States without fear of being turned away
at all
but tonight some news broke on a
separate issue that might help stem this
flow this is a huge blow to the bite
Administration a federal judge just
ruled that Trump's remain in Mexico
policy which sends certain non-mexican
citizens who entered the U.S back to
Mexico as they wait for their
immigration hearings that must remain in
place joining me now live from El Paso
is Julio Rosa senior writer for Town
Hall Julio the Biden Administration
never wanted to keep remain in Mexico
hated it because it actually worked and
they want an open border obviously do
you think this is going to have any
major effect regarding what you're
seeing on the ground which is staggering
uh at the moment I don't think so
because you have to remember that a lot
of people have been waiting since all
the way back in May when title 42 was
supposed to be gone back then before a
judge said it had a stay there's been a
lot of people waiting for next week to
to come to come to pass and so I don't
think one the news will reach them that
remain in Mexico will be in place in in
at least for a little bit and I mean the
reason why we're seeing this massive
Rush right now even the week before is
just because people are tired of waiting
and they definitely want to take
advantage of the the policies that the
by Administration has put in place since
they got into office Julio where are
these people coming from I know they're
everyone thinks it's just Guatemala and
El Salvador maybe a few South American
countries but what's the truth about the
various places of origin for these
migrants
uh well when I was in co.j Juarez for
the past two days I've met people from
Ecuador uh people from Colombia I even
met a man and his uh his wife and his
child and they were from China they were
Chinese and they uh they definitely
stood out to me um and even just even
just now as we were getting ready to for
for this shot um just right over to my
right here uh for nicaraguans hopped
over the older border fence uh and
there's a El Paso police officer and
he's called border patrol but that just
shows how busy this area has been for
the past couple of weeks and really it's
just uh it's a wait and see a lot of
Venezuelans right now they they are
mainly staying in Mexico because tile 42
does largely apply to them and from
those that I've spoken to uh the past
couple days they're they're they're
ready for next week to come over
all right secretary mayorkas um who the
Republicans want to impeach was where
you are in El Paso over the past couple
of days he met there with border patrol
agents and it did not go well Julio One
agent asked or stated they asked him why
he's staying at the border saying the
border is secure when we have no agents
in the field and that same agent said he
had the nerve to respond that he never
said the Border was Secure
and I wish you could see into our agents
eyes they were lifeless Julio
what are the agents telling you I can't
imagine the life of a border patrol
agent looking at this mass of humanity
that you showed in that video we'll show
it again in a moment
I mean I mean the Asians that I've
spoken to you know all throughout since
this crisis has started they are
absolutely demoralized they're fed up
with the lies that the bite
Administration has told the American
people because they see it they see it
every day they they have been through
multiple administrations some of them
and they've seen the differences
firsthand and so uh it for a lot of them
it's insulting that secretary mayorkas
would even say such a thing when he has
said time and again in front of Congress
even that they have operational control
that it is secure when you know from
from from what I've seen in my multiple
trips down here and even as I've seen
this past week it's it's not secure in
any traditional sense oh yeah that's
kind of obvious don't you like scores is
not secure I mean this is ridiculous
this is a complete travesty from
beginning to end this is purposeful they
wanted to do this and anyone watching
who's had a chance to watch Fox so the
other networks won't cover it sees
what's going on here they understand it
Julio thank you for being there and
thanks for that exclusive video tonight
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else